a ver es un golpe muy fuerte para el
titular del ejecutivo federal hoy
prácticamente todos los titulares de los
periódicos las redacciones de radio de
televisión
comenzaron en su teaser con la
información de que había perdido la
votación de la reforma energética el
presidente de izquierda pero poco tiempo
le duró el triunfo a la oposición porque
ayer por la noche el presidente envió
una reforma a la ley minera y hace
apenas unas horas a que nuestro país se
acaba de aprobar que la exploración la
explotación y el aprovechamiento del
litio es exclusivo del estado mexicano
para darnos una idea y ponerlo en
contexto valentina hace 16 meses una
tonelada de litio valía 7 mil dólares
americanos hoy va de 78 mil dólares me
explican los especialistas que este
mineral
almacena la energía y se está utilizando
sobre todo en la industria de los
teléfonos inteligentes y los automóviles
eléctricos y ahí hay un gran negocio
creo que el presidente ayer fue
derrotado pero hoy te levanta con una
victoria muy importante vale pero es
decir este plan b que anuncia el
mandatario sobre el litio ya queda
probado ya empieza a entrar en vigor
efe únicamente falta que vaya al senado
de la república y es mero trámite vale
la vida la cámara de origen pues la
cámara de los diputados donde por cierto
la oposición encabezada por el pp
se dice de izquierda a la derecha
encabezada por
acción nacional y el pri que gobernó por
más de 70 años salieron del pleno de la
cámara de los diputados ya fue aprobado
y ahora va al senado de la república
donde morena y sus aliados junto con el
pt y verde ecologísta lo van a aprobar
es decir es mero trámite hay que
recordar que la diferencia entre la
reforma energética y la reforma minera
que hoy se aprobó en la cámara de los
diputados es que la primera necesitaba
un cambio constitucional y una mayoría
calificada es decir tres cuartas partes
en el caso de la minera el simple
50 +1 le da la oportunidad al presidente
de la república de que después de que
vaya al senado se publique en el diario
oficial de la federación y en ese
momento entre en vigor querida valentina
y volviendo un poco a este revés qué
implicaciones tienen términos políticos
que la oposición se haya unido y haya
logrado frenar una iniciativa impulsada
por el presidente
sin duda alguna es un golpe muy
importante severo para el presidente de
la república pero
algunos exageran desde mi punto de vista
de que ya se acabó el obradorismo en
mexico a ver esto es una falacia es una
tontería el presidente tiene el control
del aparato efectivo y no tiene la
mayoría calificada pero si la mayoría
simple en la cámara de los diputados y
en mexico se van renovando los órganos
constitucionales autónomos de manera
alternada y el presidente envía a la
cámara
del senado oa la cámara de los diputados
intenta su tercia sus propuestas y se
van renovando para el 2024 cuando será
la elección presidencial
prácticamente tendrá el control de todo
valentina y en escasas 56 semanas en
méxico va a haber elecciones para
renovar gobernadores de seis estados hay
que recordar que tenemos 32 entidades
pero 6 de ellas van a ser renovadas en
nuestro país y en todas las encuestas
todos los ejercicios demoscópicos hablan
de que cuatro de los va a quedar morena
de únicamente dos la oposición por
cierto estos dos son estados muy
pequeños que no aportan muchos votos ni
mucho dinero a la economía nacional los
nombres son aguascalientes y durango
pero se quedaría morena oaxaca
quintana roo donde destacan un el estado
de hidalgo y el estado de tamaulipas
frontera con los estados unidos y en el
2023 valentina habrá dos selecciones
estarán en juego coahuila y el estado de
méxico james gray que gobernó 32
entidades únicamente se va a quedar 2
para huila y el estado de